[Música]
ya comienzan a cerrar las urnas en chile
y la suerte está echada sobre Quiénes
Serán las 50 personas que conformen el
consejo constitucional Ellos tendrán la
última palabra sobre la segunda versión
de la Carta Magna ampliamos desde
Santiago
la provincia de Alberta en Canadá entra
en estado de emergencia por los
incendios forestales más de 24.000
personas han sido evacuadas Y
actualmente hay 110 fuegos activos de
los cuales 36 están fuera de control
Siria vuelve a ser parte de la liga
árabe los países del colectivo lo
reamitieron casi 12 años después de
haberlo expulsado por la violenta
represión que desencadenó el presidente
contra los manifestantes en los orígenes
de la actual Guerra Civil
Bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
las noticias en France 24 de los saluda
María Clara calle
empezamos en Chile donde cerraron las
urnas de las votaciones para el consejo
constitucional la 50 personas que sean
elegidas recibirán la propuesta de
constitución política que ha redactado
el comité de expertos y tomarán las
decisiones finales sobre este segundo
intento por renovar la Carta Magna en
Santiago está nuestra corresponsal
Patricia Luna Patricia bienvenida Y
cuéntenos qué está pasando a esta hora
en medio del cierre de las votaciones
cierran las urnas en Chile llamados a
los últimos votantes vemos algunos que
llegan corriendo en el último minuto y
en una jornada que ha sido especialmente
tranquila en el país en una jornada
también marcada por la participación
aunque no una participación tan masiva
como la que vimos en la elección
anterior eran 15 millones de chilenos
los llamados a las urnas esperaba la
participación de entre 11 y 12 millones
de ellos en unas votaciones con voto
obligatorio marcadas un poco por la
desesperanza la apatía el
desconocimiento de los candidatos para
elegir a esas 50 personas que van a
redactar un segundo intento de texto
constitucional tras el rechazo del de la
primera intento ocurrido en octubre del
año septiembre del año 2022 eso
será
importante ver cuáles son las fuerzas
que se imponen en la elección en estos
50 candidatos que tendrán un
anteproyecto de texto ya diseña por un
comité de expertos que fue elegido por
el congreso en un proceso mucho más
marcado por la institucionalización
política por los partidos políticos que
han dirigido el proceso de incertidumbre
en las urnas sobre estos resultados que
van a definir el futuro político de el
texto constitucional en este segundo
intento y unos resultados Patricia que
se conocerán alrededor de las ocho de la
noche hora local y que cubriremos por
supuesto también aquí en France 24
entonces luego nos conectaremos de nuevo
con usted por ahora cambiamos de noticia
porque Perú registró su accidente minero
más mortal desde el año 2000 que deja
por ahora 27 fallecidos un incendio se
desató en una pequeña mina de oro en la
región de Arequipa en el sur el gobierno
local de yanaquiwa atribuye la
conflagración a un corto circuito que
ocurrió en la madrugada del sábado los
familiares de las víctimas tuvieron que
ir hasta el socavón porque la empresa no
dio información sobre el hecho
también hay incendios en Canadá pero
allí son forestales las autoridades de
la provincia de Alberta decretaron
estado de emergencia y cerca de 24.000
personas han sido evacuadas las
inusuales temperaturas de los últimos
días serían la causa principal de las
conflagraciones todos los detalles en el
siguiente reporte
filas interminables de conductores
desesperados por llegar a un lugar
seguro miles de residentes del suroeste
del estado de Alberta buscan huir de las
llamas y acatar la orden de evacuación
emitida por las autoridades mientras un
feroz incendio se acerca a zonas
residenciales
no se hayan ido
estoy un poco ansioso por lo que pase Y
como estaba todo cuando volvamos
no sé si nuestra casa todavía estará
allí mañana no lo sé
en el Horizonte la manta de humo opaco
solo se hace más grande la provincia
occidental de Canadá ha estado en llamas
Durante los últimos días 25.000 personas
ya han tenido que huir de sus hogares
algunas incluso teniendo que conducir a
través de las llamas Los Fuertes vientos
hacen que los incendios forestales
continúen avanzando en el suelo seco y
boscoso incluso amenazando las
operaciones de extracción de petróleo en
la región las autoridades locales han
declarado el estado de emergencia
actualmente hay 103 incendios forestales
activos en Alberta que queman
121.909 hectáreas y desde ayer ha habido
35 nuevos incendios forestales a pesar
del despliegue de los cuerpos de Socorro
un tercio de los incendios siguen fuera
de control debido a las altas
temperaturas que se están presentando
durante esta temporada de primavera en
Alberta de 10 a 15 grados centígrados
por encima de lo normal ahora hagamos un
breve recorrido por lo que está pasando
con decenas de migrantes en distintas
partes del mundo y comenzamos en Texas
Estados Unidos un hombre atropelló a
varias personas a las afueras de un
refugio de migrantes en Brownsville
siete personas murieron y otras más
quedaron heridas la mayoría de las
víctimas son venezolanas y el conductor
fue detenido
115 venezolanos fueron repatriados desde
Chile en un avión humanitario que envió
hasta allí el gobierno de Venezuela
ellos estaban varados en la frontera
peruano chilena desde que Lima decretó
estado de emergencia por el aumento de
migración
y más de 1400 migrantes llegaron al
puerto italiano de lampedusa todo esto
en tan solo 24 horas con ellas en los
centros de acogida ya hay 1700 personas
cuando la capacidad máxima es de 400 por
ello alrededor de 400 migrantes fueron
trasladados en buques hacia tres
albergues en la isla de sicilia
y Siria regresa a la liga árabe después
de haber sido suspendido del colectivo
en 2011 los delegados de la liga se
reunieron en El Cairo Egipto y allí
decidieron readmitir al gobierno de
bachar al azar a pesar de que cuando
inició la Guerra lo apartaron por su
violenta represión contra los
manifestantes antigobernamentales
Estados Unidos respondió y afirmó que se
opone al reintegro Rafael Pérez tiene
los detalles en el siguiente reporte
tras 12 años de suspensión Siria es
readmitida en la liga árabe la decisión
fue tomada a Puerta cerrada por los
ministros de exteriores de los países
miembros del organismo el reingreso vino
acompañado entre otros aspectos de un
llamado de atención a los actores del
conflicto interno sidio para resolver la
crisis
es necesario defender el concepto de una
patria integral y segura y el
cumplimiento de cada uno de los
componentes del gobierno sirio las
fuerzas nacionales la comunidad
internacional y los países interesados
con sus obligaciones hacia los demás
para que Siria vuelva a los sirios
unificada estable e independiente
la resolución no contó con un respaldo
unánime varios estados entre ellos Qatar
se oponen a una reapertura con Damasco
sin tener sobre la mesa una solución
política en este sentido se creará una
comisión conformada por varias naciones
y el secretario general de la liga para
buscar soluciones a la guerra civil
el regreso de Siria es el comienzo de un
movimiento no el final la dirección de
la resolución de la crisis llevará
tiempo para que se apliquen los
procedimientos será gradual la tarea de
esta comisión es hacer seguimientos de
estos procedimientos el gobierno sirio
reaccionó con un pedido el desarrollo de
un enfoque efectivo basado sobre el
respeto mutuo entre los estados miembros
de la liga árabe Siria fue expulsada en
el año 2011 tras la represión de las
fuerzas del orden contra las protestas
que pedían un cambio de gobierno
los manifestantes reclamaban El Fin Del
mandato de la familia al azar tras 40
años en el poder
pasamos a la actualidad de la guerra en
Ucrania el ejército de este país
advirtió que los rusos están evacuando a
sus ciudadanos que viven cerca de la
central nuclear de saporilla una ciudad
que controlan parcialmente según los
militares los rusos trasladaron a las
poblaciones a dos sitios en la costa del
mar de asoff mientras que Rusia señaló
que destruyó 32 drones ucranianos en un
intento por controlar la ciudad de
y nos vamos a Europa concretamente al
norte europeo porque sigue en las
celebraciones en Reino Unido por la
coronación del Rey Carlos tercero este
domingo los británicos aprovecharon el
buen clima con pollo y carne a la
parrilla de ese venado se reunieron en
el llamado gran almuerzo para festejar
además A las afueras del castillo de
Windsor se realiza un concierto con
artistas como Katy Perry y Andrea
Bocelli el príncipe William habló al
inicio del evento y afirmó que está muy
orgulloso de su padre
así terminamos las noticias los
invitamos a que vean más en France 24 y
en France 24.com
[Música]